يبدو ان صيف اهل المصري محمد صلاح لن يكون
جيدا من الناحيه التسويقيه للاسف بعد
انخفاض قيمته الماليه بالفعل تقرير منظمه
مرصد كره القدم اكد ان النجم المصري فقد
نحو ثلث قيمته السوقيه هذا العام
التقنيه صلاح التسويقيه تساوي نحو 61
مليون يورو هذا الصيف بعد ان تجاوزت قيمته
من قبل عام واحد فقط احتل صلاح المركز
الثامن بين لاعبي ليفربول الاعلى قيمه في
التشكيله الحاليه فيما جاء نجم مانشستر
سيتي
في المركز الاول بقيمه
2005 مليون يورو فقط لا غير وشو السبب
لانه احرز اهداف زي ما كان في في سنين
صلاح لم يكن بذاك المستوى اللي اللي كان
يقدمه في الموسم السابق واللي قبله واللي
قبله لذلك انخفضت القيمه السوقيه بينما
هالاند الوافد الجديد الى الدوري
الانجليزي كان
هل هذا يعني شيء طبيعي وعادي في مسيره اي
لاعب كره قدم يعني يعني شوي فوق شوي تحت
المشكله انه ثلث قيمته يعني مش 10% مش
عشرين
اربعين الى اربعين بالمئه من قيمته فهذا
الرقم خطير جدا اللقاح اضافه الى العمله
يعني في كره القدم اليوم لم يصبح لك الرقم
الصغير وايضا ليس بالنسبه للكبير لانه
رونالدو موجود ايضا كبير بالعمر ميسي ميسي
ورونالدو لكن ايضا كمحترف في عالم كره
القدم هو يصنع ماده يصنع تسويق بالتالي هو
يسوق لشركات
سيعود وراح
يرجعون للمحبي صلاح مو صلاح
فرعون لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات